good morning it's tuesday greetings from
the floor of a hotel room i loved your
video last week so much it was poignant
and beautifully written and genuinely
one of my all-time favorite vlogbrothers
videos i just had one small issue with
it which is that you told me you were
going to upload that one secret video
and then i was going to upload my secret
video in response so i wouldn't have to
make a video on vacation but i can't do
that because my secret video doesn't
make any sense without your secret video
which you didn't upload hold on i just
realized something i don't have my good
camera but i do have my good microphone
oh hi hello there welcome to cool sounds
with john green oh crap i just had a
terrible idea that i love all right so
yesterday a 12 year old family friend
quizzed me on all the celebrities i've
ever met and then after this kid had
compiled a truly exhaustive list of such
famous people he asked me a question of
all the celebrities you've met which one
would make the best president so we're
doing that while looking at the ocean
let's begin with elon musk whom i met at
a fancy dinner and who had a shockingly
exhaustive knowledge of vlogbrothers and
our related projects anyway later that
night i invited him to karaoke but he
was busy he was born outside the united
states so i have successfully dodged
that question i met laura dern because
she was in the fault in our stars movie
and we became friends she is a great mom
and person and actor and i do not think
she would ever even faintly consider the
idea of running for president which is
one of her many character assets but i
would vote for her joe biden asked me to
co-host a stop on his book tour several
years ago and he was so empathetic and
such an engaged and careful listener
that i made an entire video about my
experience with him additionally he has
40 years of experience in governance now
i wish he was a little younger but i
also think that joe biden wishes he was
a little younger still i happily voted
for him and i'm very glad that i did
dwayne the rock johnson handed me an mtv
movie award in i think 2015 and then
backstage we had a brief conversation
that i don't remember because i was so
profoundly distracted by the irl site of
his biceps which genuinely defy
everything i previously understood about
human physiology now the rock has never
held elected office and i probably
wouldn't vote for him but i will say his
guns would intimidate the hell out of
our enemies have i ever had extremely
negative experiences with celebrities
who i definitely would not vote for
yeah but i suppose i should interrupt
myself here and say that being famous is
really weird and far less pleasant than
it's made out to be like when i was in
middle school i couldn't shake this
terrible feeling that everyone was
looking at me and judging me and
thinking about what an idiot i was and
so on but the thing about being famous
is that that middle school feeling is
kind of true
like if you're serena williams and
you're in a restaurant or reading a book
by a hotel pool or whatever people are
looking at you and potentially even
photographing you for public consumption
and so i try to remind myself of that
when interacting with famous people that
they may be having a bad day and also
that they are experiencing a lot of
pressure whenever they're in public all
that noted i met rand paul at a dinner
party once and uh i would not vote for
him you know who i would vote for ryan
reynolds and yes i know he was born in
canada but i would amend the
constitution for him also almost all the
literary celebrities i've met have been
very kind like zadie smith was extremely
nice to me even though i was a babbling
bundle of nerves during our brief
conversation she's also not eligible to
be president but we already amended the
constitution for ryan reynolds so i'd
vote for her but of all the
non-political celebrities i've ever met
you know who i genuinely think would
make the best american president hank
green although i hope you never run
because i need you making vlogbrothers
videos like the wonderful one you made
last week hank i'll see you on friday
man this video was a uh was a journey
hope you enjoy the waves